a surprise we all needed Paul Walker's
daughter meadow shared a heartwarming
never-before-seen video of her late
father on Tuesday in the sweet Instagram
post meadow is seen opening the door to
surprise her dad on his birthday his
adorable reaction says it all Paul gives
meadow a gigantic hug as they both fall
on the bed then now 21 year-old
captioned the post I never thought I'd
shared this but it felt right the dream
is to have it all who says you can't
have your cake and eat it too live this
life that life this life you know we
live one time I want to get it on it's
been almost seven years since Paul
Walker's death the actor was 40 years
old when he was killed in a car accident
Paul was in the passenger seat in a
Porsche Carrera GT that crashed and
exploded in Santa Clarita California
your daughter must think you're like the
coolest dad in the whole world
she thinks I'm a dork she meadow
previously paid tribute to her dad on
his birthday back in September the photo
shows the Fast and the Furious star
hugging his daughter when she was just a
little girl she wrote happy birthday to
the loveliest soul I'll ever know et
talked to Paul back in 2003 he joked
that meadow who was just in preschool at
the time didn't know how famous her dad
was I think cyma car mechanics he asked
me what I do for a living until I work
on cars I actually had to take her on
set with me anyways apparently she
started crying you know she wanted to
see daddy so he goes into the stage and
she's looking at me like also reflects
like what tell me there's cameras set up
everywhere this big bright green screen
because it's all the green screen stuff
and there's a car and I see you I jumped
out of the car I got underneath the hood
of it I ran over to her because daddy
what are you doing I'm like I just I'm
just fixing the car and we're out the
door
she hasn't no clue no clue but her mom
calls me up it was actually yesterday
and she goes uh we got a problem like
what's that she's like metals convinced
you
is on the side of a bus I'm like well it
is she doesn't know but it isn't it's
just a matter of time till she puts it
together meadow has kept her father's
memory alive with the Paul Walker
Foundation the organization is teaming
up with the Los Angeles Regional Food
Bank to provide children with meals
during the corona virus pandemic she
encouraged everyone on Instagram to
please stay home this protects not only
you but everyone around you we need to
look out for each other during this time
and all times